[Music]
I'm James Marshall I'm not in the math
of the song the toughest foot race in
the world
it's six marathons in five days across
the Sahara Desert I'm training like a
crazy man which is really boring so
whilst my powers to come on a job to
keep me company
this is jogging meet James
[Music]
oh yeah yeah I'm doing this play now
these Golden Age yeah I can't wait to go
I'm just a hat pin fur hat hair is
really long right now I feel like a bum
one thing I always want to Howard like
shave my head no super short hair you
don't shave said I'd look like a monkey
I would look like a monkey I've done it
before
yeah there's nothing better than doing a
play in New York it's just it becomes
like a really interesting chapter in
your life so you've done loads of movies
so a lot of television why do you if
you've got all these movies I know I
just like to work I just like to get out
there and work and work on characters
it's kind of just what I do for a living
sometimes they pay you a lot and you
don't have to work that hard to make
your character you work really hard and
you don't pay you a lot when you do
theater that's kind of how that goes and
it's weird job it's just a very weird
job come on James
want to touch on Lincoln oh my oh yeah
yeah so you played in Underwood that he
was the leader of the Democratic
minority and the UH in the house I tried
to block the bill to free the slaves
what I love about Stephens movie is that
statements yeah
oh god you know I really did that but
what I love so much about his movies
that makes that point that democracy is
how we solve our differences without
killing each other yeah I love the [ __ ]
people wear with Iran I mean look at the
[ __ ] I'm wearing and what the hell is
this crazy costume please tie it on fine
huffing and puffing over there you hit
up the jackpot of super fans there
Twihards there Tolkien Heights
and the history buffs I know yeah
reenactors at first we were roaring
Lincoln fancy reenactors I did my
research on some of the fans and I Evan
look I'm talking about capital L only
evil you know a lot of them come to the
play which is nice really nice and they
kind of wait around after to you know
get a picture whatever and I just
appreciate that you know Twilight kind
of does get that community of people
together and they just excited about you
know what the actors in those movies are
doing
[Music]
okay so we've got a little game or shag
married push off a cliff okay Oprah
Martha Stewart and her Royal Highness
Queen Elizabeth a second and be careful
here
I'd marry Oprah Martha Stewart that's
all right Queen Elizabeth Queen Mary
if I push I believe I get to come to
treatment well thanks so much they feel
dijanna James
very much appreciate it performance on
[Music]
that's the show thanks for subscribing
to GQ you can trained us by following GQ
jog like us and comment below have a
great day of New York Trinity
wait